I'm gonna tell you why
the Netherlands will do very well that Eurovision 2024.
But why you're not gonna win.
First of all
I wanna say
I love the song Euro papa so much.
But this is just my analysis.
And for this video
we're gonna say
the Netherlands are already in the final,
cause they already basically are.
So let's start off with the public vote.
Euro papa can definitely win the public function
Eurovision. It is so fresh, so unique.
If there's good vocals,
good rap, if the staging is epic,
if the story from the music video
of his two parents dying,
if that's put into the live performance
and the viewers can feel an emotional connection.
And people watching a homo just think it's so cool.
Some people may think it's a carry out rip off.
Carry out from wish.
Not my thoughts,
but other people's thoughts.
But yeah, if it's slick,
professional phone,
it definitely could win the public vote.
There will be competition from RIM,
Tim Tyke, dim from Croatia,
but definitely still can win.
Now let's talk about the Jerry's.
The Jerry's are 50%.
And there's a reason why
Euro papa is not gonna win Eurovision.
Let's say if Euro papa wins the public vote
and gets a huge score.
You need this much from the jury's to win your vision.
Euro papa is only capable of getting this much
from the jury's.
This much does not equal this much.
Which means
Euro Papa cannot win Eurovision.
I'm not saying
the jury's are gonna absolutely detest Euro papa,
but in reality
there is a bit of game of key lyrics.
The song is a bit game of key.
And like Cha Cha Cha
last year only got 150 points from the Jerry's.
The Jerry's just don't like rap.
They're not gonna give it over 200.
And if your old papa
cannot get over 180 points from the Jerry's,
it cannot win Eurovision.
And I don't think it can get over 180 points.
Like if we switch tables,
like Australia like
got a huge Jerry score in 2016,
they got over 300 points,
but then they got 190 points from the public.
Let's say if you do really well in one category
and okay in another category,
that's not enough to win Eurovision.
So I think Euro papa can do very well.
It can come top five,
it can even come second.
But the maths are not there
for Euro papa to win Eurovision 2024.